and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome to episode 174 today
we're going to talk about minimalist
health and fitness and we have Ben
Greenfield here because we're gonna talk
about fitness you might as well bring in
someone who's fit yeah so we can talk
about it and so Ben thank you for being
here today man well thank you for having
me and and for fueling me with this
wonderful wonderful dark beverage my
lifeblood I had 1 cup and then Ryan
brought an entire pitcher well I need a
coffee I know podcast on drinks coffee
so yeah we'll probably make it through
this is a courtesy of we work they they
do a pretty decent job yeah you're gonna
like our band of coffee much more I
think ok yeah I'm looking forward to try
it I smelled it and it was absolutely
wonderful
yeah very good stuttery floral now Ben
you are a bit of a maximalist when it
comes to to health folks can listen to
you on the Ben Greenfield fitness
podcast and you do a lot of sort of self
experimentation you talked a little bit
about that what would drive you to be so
curious about about any pigging yes as
they say the highly scientific term you
know I think for me it sparks from my
early days you know when I was in
college I was studying a lot of this
stuff I'd I was getting my master's
degree in exercise physiology and
biomechanics so I was already kind of a
student of the human body and I wanted
to go to medical school I wanted to be a
physician and at the same time I was
also doing bodybuilding which is which
is you know if we were going to throw
around that slightly silly and off
overused term biohacking you know
bodybuilders were like some of the
original biohackers you lurk on these
forums and they're using all sorts of
Fringe peptides and and lotions and and
and you know androgen modulators and all
these things to allow them to get up on
stage with with inhuman amounts of body
fat and
in copious amounts of muscle and when
you're trying to do that when you're
trying to tweak the human body in that
manner you do have to pay attention to a
lot you have to know if your banana is
70 calories or 80 calories and whether
or not those five cans of tuna fish that
you have for dinner should should have a
little bit of extra dab of ketchup to
them or not so that you know your sugar
content for the day and so every little
thing makes a difference everything and
so for me early on you know if I was
studying human science and at the same
time using myself as almost like a
platform to test a lot of these things
that I was learning in my exercise
physiology class you know what does
creatine do what is what is nitric oxide
do what happens if you use you know
whatever red line with ephedrine
caffeine whatever else was in it back in
the day to your body fat percentages and
from there I pivoted into the next most
unhealthy sport on the planet triathlon
which is which is equally kind of like a
self hacking sport it's like how can I
figure out how to keep my ass on this
bike for for another thirty miles you
know how how can I make it through the
through the water for two miles or three
miles how can I
stave off a cramp what causes a cramp
how much carbohydrate do you need each
hour how much water before you develop
water intoxication versus dehydration
and so you know they even say in
triathlon that you know people consider
to be swim bike run but the fourth
discipline is nutrition so I studied up
a lot on nutrition and of course
continue to use myself as a guinea pig
in that sector and you know continuing
on down the road now it's more about how
do you make the human body as healthy as
possible you know now that I'm I'm 37
I'm far more interested in health and
specifically in things like anti-aging
and longevity like what kind of things
can you do to to keep your telomeres
from shortening what kind of things will
will reduce your your glycemic
variability your blood glucose
fluctuations during the day
or what kind of things will will lower
inflammation you know because I consider
inflammation and blood glucose to be the
two most important things to track for
longevity and so now I'm doing a lot of
that but initially was a combination
just education and in trying to figure
out how I could pose on stage in a
speedo and look better
dude I thought that you were the
youngest looking 37 year old but now Ben
Ben I'm sorry man he looks way younger
81 81 as well yeah December 20th 1981 oh
no three three 80s babies yeah October
23rd we've got a bunch of questions from
our audience so let's go ahead and dive
in we'll be using
Ben's maximalist experience to distill
down some sort of minimalist principles
out of it so you've done a whole lot in
your own life sort of testing on
yourself but also you've worked with a
lot of other people as a personal
trainer as a coach and in helping people
understand sort of the the minimum
viable exercises to maintain healthy
fitness without maybe diving all the way
in like you have and so I think we can
help some folks out today our first
voicemail is from Hayden and well she's
not from a city she's from patreon from
the world man how can i balance
maintaining an exercise regimen without
overwhelming myself you've talked before
about how creating and achieving goals
can kind of bog us down and I'm finding
that that's happening to me in regards
to keeping to an exercise regimen I work
two jobs and run a small resale business
from home so it's hard for me to come
home from my nine-to-five and then like
go to the gym on top of cooking dinner
cleaning up and just taking care of all
my other responsibilities because I just
don't have the energy so Ben what what
do you would you if Hayden was here in
front of you what would you talk to her
about when she says I don't have the
energy or exercises bogging me down yes
Hayden we live in almost this unfair era
in which the the form of exercise that
used to be relegated to gladiators and
Olympians and professional athletes and
the world's hard-charging warriors
has now trickled down to be something
that the general population feels that
they should be doing to feel good about
themselves to actually lose weight or to
actually be fit they need to get to the
gym and do a formal exercise session and
it's not helped out by the fact that
when you flip open any magazine you feel
like you need to not only do that but
also infrared yoga and your deep-tissue
fascial stretching session and your
peloton session and oh heck peloton just
came out with a treadmill so I got it I
got to do one of those sessions too and
you know then you throw in the internet
of things with all these fancy exercise
devices
you know half a dozen of which show up
at my house every week and I fall into
the same category I'm like how am I
going to weave this into my routine and
it bogs things down even more but when
you step back and you look at things you
look at these these blue zones for
example right like Nicoya or Sardinia or
Okinawa or Loma Linda or any areas where
people are happy and they're living a
long job of hundred years
healthy yes many many centenarians
people with people who live a
disproportionately long long amount of
time you don't see these formal exercise
in a can sessions in these communities
you don't you don't see the pressure
right to get up the hour earlier to go
hit the gym or I'm so tired I'm on the
way home from work but I have to go to
the gym because that is that that's what
society expects of me and therefore
that's how I feel good about myself
these people instead they're engaged in
low-level physical activity all day long
all right they've they they they granted
live lifestyles in many cases in which
they're hunting gathering gardening
walking cycling moving throughout the
day and that might sound unfair you know
we're right now where we're at a
facility where there's a bunch of people
you know in in cubicles and we're
indoors and you know I'm a blogger and a
podcaster I'm relegated to to a desk
much of the time but even in that
scenario you can hack your environment
you know my my office has a treadmill
workstation and a little balance board
that I stand on while I'm typing and
I've got a little kettlebell behind me
so I can stop and do kettlebell swings
I've got a pull-up bar in the door of my
office my goal by the time I
finished a day of work and taken a lot
of these so called Pomodoro breaks you
know every 55 minutes or every 25
minutes you know it depends on the day
and what I'm doing and how deep my work
is is to arrive at the end of the day
with exercise being an option not a
necessity
meaning that you you shouldn't feel as
though you finished the day of work and
been so sedentary during that day they
have to go to the gym if you are
training for it for an Ironman triathlon
you know whatever your personal Mount
Neverest is or like a Spartan Race or
maybe a fitness competition or the
CrossFit Games sure you kind of have to
go crush yourself right but don't fool
yourself into thinking that's what it
takes to be healthy or fit or to lose
weight you need sunshine fresh air low
level physical activity stopping every
once in a while during the day to lift
something heavy to move to spark the
heartrate and by the time you've gotten
to the end of the day you would be
surprised at how much when you look back
you've done I'll give you one more
example when I go to a conference where
I think you're busy right here you're in
out conferences and you're networking
with people and there's the lunches and
and your schedules thrown out of whack
and it's very difficult sometimes to get
into the gym at the beginning in the day
I have a very simple technique I have
these little lifestyle rules that I live
by right I do 20 squats whenever I use
the bathroom on an airplane well hold on
real tight when I went to go get him
downstairs in the lobby he was doing
like a warrior you were transitioning
for maybe a warrior one to a warrior to
post he's over there in the lobby ahsoka
usually some ones down the lobby that
they're either standing there or seated
and I see this tall guy who's just like
this if you're watching this on YouTube
yes but think about that I don't I don't
have to go hunt down a core power yoga
infrared session at the end of the day
today cuz I do that's I just weave that
stuff throughout my day so I've got
these rules but you know to close the
loop on that conference example when I'm
at a conference I take a cold shower at
the beginning of the day I take a cold
shower at the end of the day right so
I'm getting my blood flowing I'm getting
a lot of these the fat loss benefits and
and
and and you know the nitric oxide
release for my body so I'm full of blood
flow and then every hour when I'm at a
conference I figure out time to slip
away and do 15 to 30 burpees so when I
get to the end of a day a long day XO so
yeah eight hours at a conference I can
squeeze in 240 burpees and ten minutes
worth of cold therapy no need to go to
the gym and when when you live life by
this rule and you figure out how to do
without breaking a sweat without having
to redo hair and makeup right that's the
key is you're never actually having to
get dressed get and get undressed shower
you know do this whole formal exercise
thing if you begin to look at life
through that lens of you just being a
physically active person who squeezes in
movement when you can squeeze it in you
get a lot less pressure to have to feel
the need to go and tackle an hour at the
gym when like Haden you're driving home
exhaust at 5:00 p.m. from the office so
when you're at the office do you have
like a set number of pull-ups that you
that you're thinking like right but okay
so everything I live life by rules every
time I walk under the pull-up bar it's
five pull-ups all right very very simple
right and for for me you know for some
people five pull-ups might be a lot for
you know for them I might say just hang
from the bar for ten seconds if you
can't do a pull-up you know just do
something but for me five pulps is
pretty easy but there's also very little
decision-making fatigue and very little
cognitive willpower for me to do that I
can finish recording whatever a two hour
long podcast and I'm I just feel smoked
but I know I can do my five pull-ups and
then just a little when I knew trouble a
lot for my coffees I've gotten to the
point where I can rarely just drink
regular coffee I got to put cinnamon and
mushroom extract and stevia and do that
so every time I turn the nutribullet on
it goes on for 60 seconds so any time
that I turn the nutribullet on I do
jumping jacks right and I'm making like
three or four of those during the day so
there's four hundred jumping jacks that
I mean and it's weird because it's
almost like Pavlov's dog now when I hear
a nutribullet or I hear a blender I'm
like jumping jacks
these simple triggers that we sometimes
talk about the same thing with the with
the pull-up bar
and my place it's actually and in our
home it's right before the bathroom so
anytime I have to go to the bathroom I
have to do I do six pull-ups I'll do six
pull-ups with exiting and throughout the
day if you do that 10 times especially
you drink a lot of water it's forcing
you to do more more pull lies I go to my
mailbox twice a day
I always walk to the mailbox and I
sprint as hard as I can back my mailbox
is it's it's like 1/8 of a mile from my
front door so for me that it's it's a
hall but but these rules become
automatic and you and they become
triggers and you get to the end of the
day and you just feel good because
you've been moving all day but you also
know that again unless you're training
for some kind of a race or some kind of
a formal competition where you really do
need to begin to train like an athlete
or warrior or a gladiator or whatever
there's just like Hayden should should
just remove that that that urge or that
that pressure that she feels to exercise
and instead just just engage in
low-level physical activity during the
day I love that man so really what it
sounds like you're saying with exercise
like the most important parts of
exercise is its getting that heart rate
up a little bit and it's getting a
little bit of resistance so that doesn't
mean that yeah we have to do a CrossFit
classes I mean we have to carve out an
hour each day to do that we could we
could find little moments during our
regular day to kind of work some of this
stuff in and pick your battles again
when you when you open you know men's
health or women's fitness renny's
magazines you always have the new
workout and the eight new move some
personal trainer came up with so they
could get the article accepted by the
magazine with exercises that they hadn't
seen before so they make up all these
funky moves and you feel like you got to
learn that move too but I mean they're
like there there are three pieces of
exercise equipment that I think if you
own you can pretty much get by the
entire day and stay pretty fits a
pull-up bar right door frame pull-up bar
you can hang anywhere if you don't one
of those get one of those elastic band
or those not elastic bands you know like
a TRX type of strap oh you can use a
door I travel with those so I'll just
hang them in the door of my hotel so
when I'm going in and out of the hotel I
can do the five pull-ups so some kind of
a pull-up apparatus some kind of a
kettlebell because a kettlebell mean you
can do swings which simulates Sprint's
you can do rows you can do
Goblet you can do so much with a
kettlebell but it has a very small
footprint or you can put that in a
cubicle and then finally if you have the
space a hex bar you guys seen a hex bar
before it is actually so a hex bar is
that funky-looking bar you can see to
the gym sometimes and you stand inside
the bar why and you and you pick it up
off the floor to do a deadlift and when
it comes to grip strength activation of
the glutes which tend to turn off when
you're sitting anyway is it in cars or
at your desk being able to rip something
off the ground and get that hormonal
release not having to deal with some of
the low back and biomechanics stuff you
can get from putting a squat bar on your
back this hex bar is amazing for
maintaining high levels of strength no
matter your age no matter the health of
your back it almost forces you to be
able to lift something heavy but keep
very good form so in the room next to my
office I have a little pile of weight
plates in this hex bar and it's always
loaded up with enough weight to make me
tired if I lift it five times okay
alright so there's another guy in the in
the fitness sector named Mark Sisson and
he kind of made this whole idea of lifts
sprint move populum you can gauge in low
level physical all day long you sprint
every once in a while you know like me
to the mailbox or doing jumping jacks
with the nutribullet or you know the
burpees at a conference or whatever and
then finally you lift something heavy
every now and again right and and for me
between the doing the pull-ups at the
door and occasionally lifting that
kettlebell and then slipping into that
room next door to my office just a few
times a day during one of my breaks and
lifting that weight off the ground just
five times sends this huge anabolic
signal to your body keeps you strong all
day long and the again the thing I like
about a hex bar is you don't have to
really warm up that dramatically to do
it you just pick that weight off the
ground keeps you with you know in good
form doesn't put a lot of stress on your
back so those three things I like that
some pull-up apparatus a kettlebell and
a hex bar and that is like that's way
better advice than what I was gonna give
Hayden it's so simple I love it my wife
has been using the hex bar at her gym
she sort of does it's not across the
thing but it's it's a gym that she goes
to and
now I tell you her butt looks amazing -
which is really nice I was gonna say
wife's butt looks amazing last thing
last thing I'll say for Hayden we'll
move on here have you seen the thing
from Derek Siver's of sever's on running
from his book anything you want we'll
put a link to the video in there but for
a book but I don't remember him talking
about running it someone turned into his
beautiful video so like I always think
about like doing the exercises that you
also want to do for me the pull-ups
thing is like I actually enjoy doing
pull-ups now I do they feel amazing and
they decompress your spine and shoulders
and you know they they do everything
that being hunched over a smartphone and
a keyboard needs to be done to reverse
all the damage from that it opens up the
spine opens up the back I mean it's it's
it's a perfect antidotes who are our
post-industrial culture being hunched
over in this defensive position who
loves yeah definitely just hanging from
the bar sometimes to make sure Jesse
compresses everything yeah to your point
that's where I started when I couldn't
do a pull-up so it was just hanging from
the bar and then eventually you can do
one and then eventually two and I first
learned to do pull-ups Ryan used to come
over and he would assist me doing
pull-ups before I could and now you know
I do them every day and it's no problem
but for a while back in my late twenties
like Ryan would come over and just like
help me you helped move me up Rick this
will be good for people to know if you
can't do a pull-up and you hang one of
these pull-up bars and you don't want to
gradually work your way up and hang
there for months at a time until you get
to the point you do the pull-up you've
no doubt seen these elastic bands yeah a
sporting goods stores these monster
bands rogue bands whatever they call
them but you hang that from either side
of the pull-up bar and then when you get
up into the pull-up bar you just kind of
put your knees onto the elastic band
like they're cradling and the elastic
band pulls you up into the pull-up and
so it's like one of those big machines
at the gym like the assisted pull-up
machine but all you need is an elastic
band and a cheap ass pull-up bar in your
door and you have the same thing yeah I
could replace Ryan with an elastic no
you know the one thing I will tell
Hayden is that I know that you feel
Hayden that you don't have the time to
exercise and it's very very overwhelming
but I would
challenged her to start looking at it in
a way that she can't afford not to
exercise because exercise is what will
give you more energy so if you're
looking for more energy I know you're
tired but ya find some of these little
things that you can do throughout the
day and it will totally boost your
energy
that's an interesting paradox too
because we think I don't have the energy
to exercise but of course in exercising
more long-term it doesn't have to be you
know the CrossFit like you said there
there are no CrossFit boxes and in the
blue zones right or at least probably
very few but but yeah I walk every day
so one of my big ways that I exercise
that I had sustained exercise I walk
about 8 to 10 miles a day so I'll
usually walked at the office or I'll
walk home I'll walk really far to get
lunch I'll go up to Runyon Canyon and
just do a loop there and and adding a
little bit of walking in into my day is
is something that I've been able to do
because well I also enjoy it right but
it gives me energy to to keep going and
it's back to that civis thing that I
wanted to talk about really quickly he
he was talking about the people who want
to run and and there are people who run
and the people who want to run but don't
run they throw up all these excuses you
know throw up 22 different reasons that
I can't run that well I have to put my
running shoes on I have to have to
shower afterward and you know I need to
make sure the right running shorts with
me and we have all these rules that we
set up these sort of rolling up your
running app that allows you to chase the
zombies in your heart rate strap so
what's your tie and yeah running running
has become very complicated right and
we've complicated that and then you have
someone who is a runner and they're
they're like what do you have to do to
get ready for run like well I just have
to start running because I enjoy running
it's a finding the thing that you enjoy
doing that removes those roadblocks for
you it automatically makes it simpler we
we complex issues and we make them more
complex by saying well here are the 17
rules I have to do first before I can
run well what is the thing that you
don't have all those rules for what's
the exercise where you can just for me
walking to to the office here it's just
like yeah I just leave my house walk to
the office act so yeah
I put my back broke and Ivan been able
to do a lot yesterday I actually got out
and I got my first like you know ten
thousand over ten thousand steps that
I've gotten since uh you know January
11th is when I had that back injury and
man like just being able to get out and
walk I mean I notice a huge difference
my sleep score was better I woke up with
a we got like the war ring I don't know
if you've heard of that but it just kind
of keeps oh yeah I got the same one it
here yeah man so I woke up this morning
with like a ninety readiness and that's
I mean it's the best readiness I've had
since I broke my back and the worst
sleep I of anyone I've ever met and I
had an outstanding sleep score last
night it was 70 that was my outstanding
sleep score well you know they're of
course a you know a an uncountable
number of sleep hacks out there now you
know from pads that you put underneath
your mattress to circulate cold water
and and binaural beats that you put in
your ears and but I've I've found that
for most people the number one thing
that allows them to sleep like a baby is
some form of temperature alteration
before bed like for me if I can do a
sauna followed by a lukewarm or a cold
shower before bed you know I did this
last night for example you just leave I
keep a sauna in my basement and I hit
that read some magazines or books and
take a cold shower and you're just out
in our gym is like a block away so it's
got a sauna there you can also just do a
hot cold contrast shower and 20 to 20
seconds of cold 10 seconds of hot a few
times through and it you know when you
plummet that core temperature it
activates the parasympathetic nervous
system and you know sure you can do
meditation breath work and all these
other things but for me temperature
regulation just works amazing I mean you
know walking to the RO many philosophers
where we're huge fans of walking now I'm
in the same boat as you I do a lot of
walking to gather my thoughts I always
have some kind of a post-it note and a
pen in my pocket so I don't have to whip
out my phone to take notes and I'm not
distracted by my device when you walk I
mean it just opens up your mind and and
there's even been research on this that
shows that walking while thinking or
pondering or even listening
to an audiobook or a podcast sparks a
significant increase in what's called
BDNF brain-derived neurotrophic factor
and this acts like miracle-gro for your
brain so if you have a problem there's
there's something very much to this this
this this ancient wisdom of sleep on it
or and this is this is lesser-known
but but very effective walk on it right
have you read Mason Curry's book daily
rituals yes yes oh so he looks at the
163 different creative people a lot of
them or writers or musicians back to
Mozart or Jonathan Franzen or whomever
and one of the commonalities amongst
almost all of them besides alcohol or
caffeine was was walking right and in
finding finding that time every day to
walk because that's where a lot of the
ideas come for all the habits of high
achievers and it is funny you actually
do see a lot of alcohol a lot of
caffeine a lot of a lot of walking you
know but about alcohol caffeine that
those could be contextualized as
unhealthy or healthy depending on how
you do them and then innings and then
yeah then you open up a book like you
know tools of titans or something like
that and now you see whatever metformin
and rapamycin and off-label
pharmaceuticals III have yet to see
those proven in very long research
studies to be equally effective but yes
walking and drinking alcohol and coffee
I think we've nailed it he's to help
success I'm gonna send you a copy of our
book essential it's an essay collection
with 150 different essays about
intentional living so if you like our
podcast you're probably like the
audiobook version of that or if you want
the book book or the e-book podcast Sean
will reach out to you and and send you
one of those as well all right before we
move on to our lightning round we have
three more voicemail questions we're
gonna answer on our maximal episode this
week on patreon in the meantime we'd
love to hear what you have to say so you
can leave a comment or a tip about
fitness or minimalist health leave us a
voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine or email a voice
memo to podcast at the minimalist
where our favorite comments and tips on
a future episode and stay tuned to the
end of this episode for this week's
listener comments and tips and here is a
pro tip for you write down your question
or your comment before you call in Ryan
what time is it you know what time it is
it it's time for our lightning round
where we answer questions from social
media indeed we do we're on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram at the
minimalists and Ben Greenfield is at Ben
Greenfield I believe on on all the
relevant platforms yes yeah you can
think some of them are at Ben Greenfield
fitness but most of them are I I wish I
wouldn't have done that too because I
I'm again more about health and fitness
these days but but yes Ben Greenfield
there Ben Greenfield fitness yeah we'll
put a link to all of his social media in
the show notes as well so you can tweet
at him Instagram at him snapchat at him
whatever you want to do you can you can
get in touch and your website is just
been in Greenfield fitness calm or
beautiful all right well this is then
this is where Ryan and I usually do our
best to answer every question which is
the short shareable less than 140
character response but not really
we've Mandar on a little bit and then we
tie it up with a little bow and Shawn
puts our pithy answers in the show notes
so people can copy and share our answers
on social media and we put all of these
in one place now minimal maxims dot-com
what's our first question Ryan our first
question is from E Patrick I go to the
gym to lift weights what are some
alternative minimalist ideas for a
resistance workout without a gym well so
for me that my pithy answer to this is
everyone has 18 minutes a day for their
health this was something I discovered
because like hayden in our earlier
question I was overwhelmed by I forgot
at the gym and that it was I put up all
these barriers for myself and then I
figured out like you can do you know
it's the 80/20 rule you can do 80% of
what you want to do in 18 minutes a day
if you you know it so every everyday
even today when I really really did not
want to do it cuz I'm not been feeling
great with the whole SIBO thing that's
going on I do I do an 18 minute exercise
it's just push-ups pull-ups squats for
18 minutes and man I'm destroyed after
that in the mornings it's like you you
run it off to do your burpees and and
and so for me everyone has that short
period of time 18 minutes like I can't
even
an excuse now because I know I have
eight I can find 18 minutes in a day
they've done oh I need to do my
lightning round sound effects studies on
on seniors and exercising individuals
and found that you stave off muscle loss
and you get a significant increase in
growth hormone when you're doing
bodyweight exercises even if you don't
have access to formal weights if you use
something called blood flow restriction
and you can go on Amazon you can buy
these things called blood flow
restriction bands they're like
tourniquets you put one around each leg
and on the arms then you go to your
push-ups
your squats your pull-ups but it
simulates lifting hundreds of pounds
because your muscles get less blood to
them so that's my tip is just go out and
do bodyweight exercises but grab
yourself for like it probably cost you
twenty thirty bucks
some of these blood flow restriction
bands off Amazon put those on before you
do your bodyweight never heard of the
formula for is called katsu it's based
on Japanese research katsu ka a TSU
katsu training will put will make sure
Sean puts a note in the in the show
notes my pity answer is this as
memberships don't make you fit
consistent action makes you fit so you
know that's just my way of saying the
same thing what we were telling you
Hayden is is it doesn't take a gym
membership to do these these exercises
it doesn't take running a marathon to be
healthy there are these little
increments these little times during the
day that we can take advantage of to to
stay healthy and not have to worry about
spending money and a member I was so
stuck in that it was like very much like
Hayden when I was in the corporate world
it was like oh man I don't have an hour
to go to the gym well I guess I won't
get fit because then I'll have that hour
and you know I don't want to pay that 80
bucks a month for the gym or whatever it
is and that is it's a defeating attitude
yeah unless you're single go to the gym
right go to the gym and go to church do
good places yeah the grocery store - all
right man our next lighting round
question is from Nasik
sunrise is running the ultimate
minimalist sport
what about yoga with just a mat how
about swimming isn't it so simple - with
questions dresses yeah
this is a very maximal amount of minimal
exercise this is the ultimate minimalist
sport
I mean yoga in an infrared sauna while
running yeah running running yoga mat
you actually do you you you have a sauna
where you and you'll do some some yoga
in it I like to stack things like that
to get the you know you put you get that
podcast you want to listen to you get
into the heat and the Sun I you do your
yoga and your breath work and you just
nail as many variables as once
absolutely so if you want to simplify
that for someone what is the ultimate
minimalist sport I mean and I have the
answer for you go for it
based on actual research on calorie
burning on blood flow on heart rate
variability on sleep the number one
activity you can do that requires very
little equipment is swimming
that's I've had a lot of people tell me
with my back like swimming is the best
thing to do may not be swimming there so
there are so many and as a matter of
fact for longevity as well
swimming actually induces a decrease in
the rate of what you're telling me or
shorten similar to like meditation for
example probably because it is very
meditative right it's it's it's almost
like float tank isolation you're usually
kind of staring at a black line above
the pool or in the dark and there's a
little bit of cold and temperature
regulation involved and there's a
swishing and your your vagus nerve gets
activated when your head goes under the
water so I'm a fan of swimming with the
caveat that I don't like these heavily
chlorinated pools at health clubs I
could lake river yeah creek whatever so
is there like a like an amount of time
or a distance that you would recommend
someone like a minimum that's for me
like fifteen to thirty minutes is a
sweet spot you get in you do some
underwater breath-hold so I'm back and
forth a few times just feels good it's
awesome well my pithy answer here is the
simplest exercise is the exercise you
enjoy just builds on that severest thing
we were talking about we we make things
very complex and your answer earlier
right about you can't buy the the gym
membership isn't what's going to make
you fit it's the same with we try to buy
our fitness in so many ways I'll buy the
the appropriate exercise bike or tread
or membership I'll buy these these
widgets that can augment the experience
for sure but they don't replace the
experience so we see those really bad
infomercials where it's like just zap my
ABS and I'll have a six-pack ABS in six
weeks the fifties thing like the it
would shake eeeh there's like the vibe
you stood on this plate and had this
band around your belly and just shake
everything in the gym when you see those
fat old lady not the stereotype on one
of those things happen or Jamba Juice
shake shake it on the vibe platform well
what's funny about about that is you
rarely see a person who's fit as has
been doing the you know the the quick
fix right trying trying to but what I
like about them we'll talk about with
him about this on the maximal episode is
he does use a lot of tools to help him
sort of dial in his fitness and and
having that simple baseline and then
being able to to augment it is something
we can also talk about yeah my pitty
answer is pretty simple it's minimal
exercises can lead to maximum health and
again that just goes to any these simple
exercises that was recommended here any
of these are good but I agree with you
just pick something that you like
something that you're inspired motivated
to do that's that's going to be the
simplest yes indeed well let's move on
to our added value portion in the show
so we talk about something has added
value to our lives recently people tend
to like my music recommendation so I'm
just gonna go with the music
recommendation today this is one of
those rarities where I found a billboard
that really because I hate
advertisements so funny my
recommendation for my billboard to
anyway keep going so so I found this
album from a guy named Jay s Jay s on
Dara and he is a singer-songwriter from
Kenya but he lives in Minneapolis and he
has a he's a song or an album called
tales of America in fact I think we'll
play out today with his song saying
goodbye which is it's just a it's a
beautiful album it's it's reminds me of
like if Dylan were alive today and could
sing well yeah Bob Dylan if he could
sing well
and I'm alive still I said you were
around today live today no I'm sorry
that if I said alive then I well I don't
know anyway yeah he might be alive
awesome
but apparently useless to Josh yes he's
dead to Josh even though he's around Bob
Dylan is like he's like one of those
very famous singer songwriters I've just
never like really been able to like get
into I actually went to one of his
concerts back in like 2001 and it was
yeah it was Noah's actually was like
Cincinnati the u.s. Bank Arena okay and
it was it was it was this great band
opening up man and like Bob Dylan wasn't
on stage yet the band just like jam and
I mean just like really really going and
getting the crowd excited and then all
of a sudden you know Bob Dylan steps out
on stage and everyone's like wow and
then like he like shimmies up to the mic
and he's like but it was really cool to
be able to see him and I'm not trying to
dog Bob Dylan or anything I think I
think Dylan's one of the best
songwriters of all time check out Jay s
on Dora tales of America the album is
great we'll play out with saying goodbye
later in this episode Ryan what's been
adding value to your life assistant Lee
so speaking of billboards in LA there's
a lot of billboards and most of them are
like music or TV or movie and we're
being beat over the head right now with
the Umbrella Academy which is on Netflix
it's like a Netflix original and when
have you heard of this at all I don't
have a minimalist III was checking it
out and it kind of looked like like an
x-men kind of knockoff type thing and so
I kind of avoided it but during you know
being laid out for the last six weeks I
just I was like I'll give it one you
don't want episode of shot and it's
really really good I mean you would hate
it cuz you don't like sci-fi stuff but
it's like this really cool sci-fi series
and things like 10 maybe 11 episodes but
it's it's awesome it's really really
good beautiful what's been adding value
to your life recently been in anything
that you should really found value and I
love music and I've got this tiny little
travel baritone ukulele and the reason I
like the baritone is that the fingering
is identical to that of a guitar okay so
I can practice
as though I'm crashing on my guitar it's
four strings but the fingering is the
same as a guitar so I can maintain my
guitar skills while I'm on the road I
found this company called fusion that
makes travel bags that fuse and connect
together and one of their bags is a
baritone ukulele bag so I've got that
attached to a backpack I put that on as
my carry-on as I go through the airport
and it allows me to play music at night
to practice my songs but it's small it's
portable and music brings joy to my
heart I absolutely love love music and
to be able to strum while I'm on the
road for a while is using a harmonica
and this is just this is just as doodles
better than a harmonica that's awesome
and so does it represent we say the
fingering does it represent like the the
top four live I want to play it be my D
on a baritone ukulele is the same as a D
on a guitar okay you know other ukuleles
that you the fingering is actually
different in the D is I believe it's
different yeah it's hard for me just an
audio cool beautiful let's move on the
right here right now so we talked about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalist before we move on to our
maximal episode it's a new month this is
coming out on April 2nd so yesterday was
the beginning of a new month which means
a new opportunity to start our 30-day
minimalism game we'll put a link to the
video for that the Jordan created with
us we we went to this like thrift shop
and paid them $60 to let us film in
there and in there like this awesome
thrift shop it was like a clutter
paradise yeah and we went in there and
so we have this thing called a 30 day
minimalism game because people the
average American household has 300,000
items in it and we don't know where to
start if we want to start decluttering
or live starting to let go that doesn't
include dust mites although we do
collect those they collect all the
things right and so we set up this game
to make well we think decluttering is
kind of boring so to make it a little
bit more fun it's called the 30 day
minimalism game you can check that out
the minimalists calm slash game there's
a video there we'll put a link to that
in the show notes also we did a home
tour of my home over on YouTube Ryan's
is coming next so if you want to check
that out it's youtube.com slash the
minimalists before we move on here I
just want to say thanks to Ben
his podcast will put a link to it as
well the Ben Greenfield fitness podcast
it's great I'm a fan of the podcast I
really enjoy it I especially love you
when you do the Q&A sessions you have a
lot of great expert guests you have some
fringe guests on some time and and what
I like about you is a lot of what you
talk about is is backed by science but
you're not afraid to occasionally dip
your toe in the woowoo
yes I interviewed a breatharian once who
believed you could survive on on your on
air and no food yes and you're willing
to challenge people like that as well
yeah which which I certainly appreciate
as long as my heir has hamburgers in it
all right this week we have three more
questions about purchasing healthy food
on a budget about mending a broken
relationship with Fitness that one will
be fascinating and about the best apps
for health I'm also gonna chat with Ben
about my own gut health
Ryan's broken back some hormone
questions and minimalist Fitness tools
to talk about the the other tools that
may be of added value to to Ben's life
you want our answers to those questions
you can listen to this week's maximal
episode available exclusively on patreon
that's right you're currently listening
to our weekly minimal episode but each
week Ryan and I record an entirely
different long-form maximal episode on
the minimalists private podcast which
gives us the private space we need to
talk about our flawed habits our family
lives our struggles our relationships
our emotions and our insecurities
without fear of judgment or public
ridicule Plus patreon is the best way
for us to fund this podcast and keep it
a hundred percent advertisement free
when you subscribe to the minimalist
private podcast on patreon you'll
receive a personal link so our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you also get access to our entire
back catalogue of more than a hundred
private podcast episodes find all the
details and all the good stuff including
an additional podcast episode every week
over at the minimalists com slash
support Ryan what else as always I just
want to encourage people to read more
and get informed and also here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners hey Josh and Ryan this is
Jansen from Memphis you may already know
about this but you can make banana
tastes like ice cream if you freeze them
and then blend them in a food processor
you can add peanut butter or honey or
other fruit to it or whatever hi Josh
and Ryan this is Teresa from Minneapolis
Minnesota Colleen in regards to the
digital clutter episode I've actually
been creating a lot of social media
recently going through each removing old
posts and accounts and this has been
tedious but it's also been a good
reminder of all the time I've wasted
currently on going through Facebook and
I wasn't planning to because I'm a
nostalgic person but it's been
eye-opening seeing all these old posts
of times that there was a lot of
not-so-great memories or times that I
had posted having a great time but I was
actually going through a hard time in my
life it's actually made it easier for me
to let go of these posts now now that
I've seen that it wasn't as great as I
remembered so that's helped me move
forward with that
one other tip for using social media on
your computer is to bookmark a different
page of that site instead of the main
page so for YouTube I have it linked to
my subscription page Facebook is linked
to a custom friends list they made of
just close friends and family that way
I'm only looking at a short condensed
page when I'm logging in and most days
I'm only spending about one or two
minutes on Facebook and YouTube just
seeing what's in there and then closing
it and being done for the day
so hopefully someone will find these
helpful and thinking have a great day
all right Joe that's it for this episode
you can comment on this episode over at
youtube.com slash the minimalists if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our email list over at the
minimalists dot-com and you'll also
receive our simple Sunday emails each
week and if you leave here today with
just one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for listen
y'all we'll see you next time minimus